Devon jeder Patient traf einen jungen Stand
hart hart auf Araucana Esmeralda ganas
min suger rief es ist so schön, dass
Sie heute hier bei uns sind,
also werde ich Sie zuerst auf Deutsch fragen und
dann werde ich wieder auf Englisch übersetzen, wenn
das für Sie so in Ordnung ist  SS Martina,
um Vishwas zu hören, ich bin Muslim und Zetas
Husky, um zu sagen, aber dennoch sexy irische Beta-
Vida in Amerika im vergangenen Jahr, also muss es
für Sie so schwer sein zu sehen, wie sich die Geschichte auf
tragische Weise gerade jetzt in
den USA wiederholt.  Wie denkst du über
alles, was gerade vor sich geht
? Leider erlebe
ich den Moment noch einmal. Ich sende definitiv mein Beileid
an die Familie. Ich fühle definitiv für die
Familie von George Floyd. Ich fühle definitiv
mit Xia durch
Lichtgleichung und wenn Amir von George Floyd
Meeresfrüchte nicht erreichen Mitya fami
enosis alpha z Giada Schwestern noch Vida würdest du
sie sind furchtlose Kämpfer ist für den Film
jung ist von Fionna shmita ich würde
elitär anpassen gefragt und zuletzt Naboo Denis
verärgerter Anblick noch genannt Kampf von
George Floyd ist Cindy Politikerin letzte
ina  Fantine ist zu sagen Wut geknackt
estas und shouldna Fauna so dass der
Polizist, der in den Fall Ihres Vaters verwickelt
war, fünf Jahre nach dem tragischen Vorfall gefeuert wurde.
Er wurde nie angeklagt. Der
Polizist in diesem Fall ist
mindestens einer von ihnen angeklagt
Leider nein, dass der
Offizier fünf Jahre später entlassen wird
, das ist keine Gerechtigkeit für mich.
Gerechtigkeit verabschiedet das AeroGarden-Gesetz
hätte zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden müssen Alle
Beamten hätten im
Fall meines Vaters entlassen werden müssen, was leider nicht der Fall war,
aber wir werden uns definitiv
für das AeroGarden-Gesetz einsetzen, das
verhindern würde, dass Autos
nicht oft als Fusée Estes zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden,
aber kein Nichkhun-Look  in fünf
jahren hatte vater ein wachsames polizeisystem und
las umgebung von atomschnäppern, denen ihre
kämpfer so schwindelig waren, aber
Eric garner law auch, und als
dreieck ist das der stoff für lieder, die ich als politiker genieße einen kerl fünf acres und britisch alle da fook  Garage Diamond Farm
für Disco Mafia, also erzähl mir mehr über
das Gesetz von Eric Garner, was genau ist das?
Ich wiederhole die Frage, das
Gesetz von Eric Garner, das du gerade voranzutreiben versuchst,
was genau wird
es in der Zukunft jetzt tun
Nun, wir drängen auf das AeroGarden-Gesetz, das
einen unabhängigen Staatsanwalt ernennen wird,
um alle Fälle von Polizeibrutalität zu untersuchen.
Alle Beamten werden auf Bundesebene
oder auf nationaler Ebene angeklagt  Wenn
wir auf Bundesebene bestanden werden wollten,
damit sie auf Bundesebene angeklagt werden können, können
sie tatsächlich Zeit
dafür verbüßen, uns getötet zu haben, und sich immer nur
um Rechenschaftspflicht zu kümmern, geht
es darum, für Ihre Handlungen zur Rechenschaft gezogen zu werden.
Sie sitzen
jemandem im Nacken und sie sind es  zu sagen, dass
sie nicht atmen können, wenn das kein Hilferuf ist
, den ich nicht kenne, und das
Gesetz von Aragon wird verhindern, dass Autos keinen
Spaß machen, es würde sie zweimal darüber nachdenken lassen,
jemandem die Atmung einzuschränken, weil
sie wissen, dass sie bundesweit
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden könnten wie mit  Die Amerikanerin Laura
Doster trifft Woody Tasha Arrestor
Fermions, sie ist dem Politikerforum
für Toshiko Martin beigetreten, der die irritierende Veniamin
Zach Akana-Stoppumgebung von Zion
Heights am meisten begeht – ein bisschen von
Josephines staubigem erwähntem Ippolit-System
bei Straftätern, ZZT Taffy Ryan macht eine
Art formelle Ökonometrie-Polizei I
Geh und hol sie, Colonel Donna. Ich mag
Nicks Perseiden-Farmen, Erze und
Bundesgesetze, während wir dumme
Einwanderer und la  nd erleichtert Gazette's Kind
Auch meine letzte Frage an Sie ist, als
Ihr Vater starb, bat Ihre Familie
alle Demonstranten, friedlich zu bleiben
und sich an seinen Namen zu erinnern. Was
ist Ihr Wunsch für die Menschen im Moment? Ich
meine, es gibt viele friedliche
Proteste, aber  Es gibt auch Unruhen im
ganzen Land. Was haben Sie dazu
zu sagen? Ich möchte nur zwei Dinge sagen.
Ich möchte nur sagen, dass Leute, die
mit George Floyd zusammenarbeiten, nicht
da sind und
schreiben, dass sie nicht plündern  Nicht
darauf, Eigentum zu zerstören, die Leute,
die gegen die Demonstranten sind
, sind diejenigen, die randalieren. Ich ermutige die Leute,
weiterhin friedlich zu protestieren
Protest Ich ermutige immer dazu,
friedlich zu protestieren, gerade jetzt befinden wir uns in einer
nationalen Krise. Ich hoffe, dass 19 echte
Hoffnung in 19 ist. Sie betrifft Schwarze, aber
Schwarze müssen ihr Leben riskieren,
um unser Leben zu retten
Ich ermutige nur jeden,
weiterhin friedlich zu randalieren und zu plündern und
Eigentum zu zerstören, ist nicht die Antwort,
und wenn Sie zu dieser Familie stehen wollen,
würden Sie kein sterbendes Licht
auf ihren Namen teilen, Sie werden kein schlechtes
Licht auf ihren geliebten George werfen  Floyd
würde nicht draußen auf den Straßen sein
und schreien und schreien und Eigentum zerstören.
George Point würde
wahrscheinlich draußen mit den anderen
Opfern von Polizeibrutalität stehen,
also hören Sie auf zu schreiben, hören Sie auf zu plündern und
protestieren Sie einfach friedlich, damit Sie
uns unterstützen und uns unterstützen können  Ganz
vielen Dank, dass Sie sich uns heute angeschlossen haben,
und ja, verbreiten Sie diese Botschaft. Vielen Dank,
und Geld, lassen Sie uns Sie haben